but um he too is 17. the same age as the
teenager nahal who was shot dead by the
police
for him it was an easy decision to go
out and join the rioting
the death of Nell I was revolted it was
a an injustice it was to attack the
symbol of the states
he was in Dante last Wednesday as
lawlessness took hold
the next night he was in obervillier as
this Northern suburb of Paris burned
did what you were doing feel wrong in
any way
I don't know me I I don't
transgressed the law so me no but but
you were part of a riot yes the riot in
general we can't avoid that if there is
a not police not another police abuse I
will not
stay in my room and just see the media's
you go out again yes
if the number of police of policemen and
the violence of policemen Heights the
violence of us will act to evolve open
come up come up yes
as we spoke on this quiet side street
and Military Patrol turned up
they slowed right down but did move on
right you okay yes
um with the death of now this is the the
proof
of
um we need to um to film control or
every time the police speak with young
people we saw that in England with but
the cops will have the body cameras the
body camera I guess I think it's a very
good idea and that would
make you more confident to deal with the
police yes yes but have you have you
achieved anything do you think
um we don't know it will be um we know
we will know that when the policeman
will be judged there are a lot of fights
to do to have Justice in this country I
think he would do it again and there are
thousands like him
the divisions at the heart of all this
seem as deep as they've ever been
Tom Parmenter Sky News Paris